sans surprise la Réunion n'aura pas duré
plus d'une heure ce matin syndical a
honoré son rendez-vous avec la première
ministre on a finalement demandé à la
première ministre de confirmer si elle
retirait cette réforme comme nous le
demandions tout et tout ça la réponse
est non choisi de mettre fin à cette
réunion inutile dès lors que la première
ministre nous a indiqué qu'elle
continuerait à gouverner contre le pays
c'est forcément un échec quand la
Première ministre ne fait aucune
ouverture sur cette discussion donc oui
c'est forcément un échec nous avons
trouvé face à nous un gouvernement
radicalisé obtus et déconnecté
c'est une gifle au visage des millions
de Françaises et de Français qui sont
dans la rue chaque organisation
syndicale a pu s'exprimer on voit que
nous avons un désaccord sur l'âge on
voit qu'il y a aussi de nombreux sujets
dont nous partageons l'importance et sur
lequel nous pourrons rediscuter
ultérieurement nous sommes prêts
lorsqu'ils seront prêts lorsqu'il le
souhaiteront à ouvrir l'ensemble de ses
chantiers d'ici là la contestation
continue comme ce matin avec cette
banderole déployée au sommet de l'Arc de
Triomphe qui reprend le mot d'ordre des
syndicats 64 ans c'est non après cette
réunion j'en appelle à ce que un maximum
de travailleurs et de travailleuses de
citoyens dans ce pays rejoignent les
cortèges partout en France demain
l'homme et la femme les plus riches au
monde sont tous les deux Français c'est
le classement Forbes pour 2023 qui le
dit il s'agit de Arnaud président
fondateur de LVMH numéro 1 mondial du
luxe et de Françoise Bettencourt Meyers
héritière de L'Oréal tout à fait normal
dans une grande démocratie comme la
France d'abord que mise à l'intérieur
rende compte aux médias évidemment mais
rendre compte devant le Parlement je
suis moi-même parlementaire le temps que
je suis ministre je ne suis pas mais il
est tout à fait logique d'être contrôlé
par les deux commissions des lois et
donc j'ai évidemment dit oui tout de
suite dès que l'on m'a invité à
m'expliquer pendant ce temps Emmanuel
Macron entame une visite d'État en Chine
le président de la République est arrivé
à Pékin ce matin en compagnie d'une
soixantaine de chefs d'entreprise
français les policiers gendarmes ne font
que répliquer à des personnes qui sont
violents ce n'est jamais eux qui en
premier iraient dans les rues et à
Sainte Soline trouverait des personnes
dans un champ et les attaqueraient c'est
en réplique Chine précisément forte de
sa relation étroite avec la Russie
encore réaffirmer ces derniers jours
peut jouer un rôle majeur notre
président est coupé du monde il vit dans
un vide informationnel depuis quelques
années il passe le plus clair de son
temps dans ses résidences que les médias
appellent avec beaucoup d'éloquence ces
bunkers il y a une propagande permanente
je dis bien permanente qui commence à
l'école qui continue à l'université qui
se fait qui continue à l'école dans les
médias à la dans la publicité je
n'aurais jamais imaginé cela possible
aux États-Unis jamais
le seul crime que j'ai commis et de
défendre courageusement la nation face à
ceux qui essaient de la détruire il
craint pathologiquement pour sa vie
il s'est entouré d'une barrière
impénétrable de quarantaine et d'une
absence totale d'information sur
internet de la vie de certains experts
le dossier d'accusation monté par la
justice new-yorkaise présenterait
certaines faiblesses regardez les
publicités c'est phénoménal le cinéma le
cinéma français et est complètement une
machine de propagande Apple placée sous
surveillance renforcée
cée ils ont du gendarme allemand de la
concurrence en raison de sa position de
force je trouve que le cinéma parfois
est un des derniers espaces de liberté
mais les séries à la télé là vous avez
raison un seul intelligence artificielle
tchatche j'ai pété le robot à Méka fait
des progrès stupéfiants dans ses
réponses et dans ses expressions
faciales tu sais ce que montre cette
nouvelle vidéo de démonstration où
l'humanoïde apprend par exemple qu'une
catastrophe naturelle va se produire
alphabet maison mère de Google méta qui
gère Facebook ou encore Amazon sont déjà
sous surveillance renforcée autre rein
et la machine
ne se laisse pas insulter sans rien dire
[Musique]